[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قال علي اكبر ولايتي كبير
مستشاري قائد الثوره الاسلاميه في ايران
ان بلاده ترفض الهدنه في سوريا وتعتبرها
ذريعه امريكيه لتغيير نظام الرئيس بشار
الاسد ياتي تصريح ولايه منافيا لموقف نائب
وزير الخارجيه حسين امير عبد اللهيان الذي
اكد قبل اسبوع تاييد ايران للهدنه نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما حقيقه
موقف ايران الفعلي من الهدنه الحاليه في
سوريا وما مدى ارتباط هذا الموقف بالتزام
النظام السوري بتنفيذ الهدنه وبقدرتها على
الصمود
في ال 24 من الشهر الماضي قال مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان
ان بلاده كانت تؤكد منذ البدايه على وقف
اطلاق النار في سوريا قرئ التصريح حينها
على انه تاييد ايراني للهدنه بيد ان
مراقبين راوه او راوا بالاحرى في لغته
الفضفاضه غير المحدده لوقف اطلاق نار
بعينه راوا فيه مؤشرات على ت حفظ طهران
على تلك الهدنه اسبوع بعد ذلك قطع علي
ولايتي كبير مستشاري المرشد قطع الشك
باليقين حين اكد ان الهدنه في سوريا
مرفوضه ايرانيا فاتحا بذلك باب التكهنات
والتاويل على مصرع تقرير فاطمه
التريكي ايران ترفض الهدنه في سوريا موقف
صريح رسمي ومن شخصيه غير عاديه في قربها
من المر شهد الاعلى للجمهوريه الايرانيه
رئيس مركز البحوث الاستراتيجيه لمجمع
تشخيص مصلحه النظام علي اكبر ولايتي قال
ان الهدنه ما هي الا ذريعه لتغيير نظام
الرئيس الاسد وتشكيل ما دعاها حكومه عميله
لامريكا في دمشق واعلن ان اي قرار في هذا
الشان يتخذ من خلال اراده الشعب السوري
وليس الامم المتحده او اي حكومات اخرى
حكومات اخرى كلمه ينبغي التوقف عندها في
تسجيل لحظه خروج ما كان همهمه عن امتعاض
ايراني من مسار الاوضاع في سوريا الى
العلن فمن المسلم به ان ما توصف
بالهدنيا هي نتاج تفاهم امريكي روسي متقدم
وروسيا شريك الهدنه هي شريك ايران في
الحرب هناك واحده في السماء واخرى على
الارض والان واحده تف فهمت على هدنه
والثانيه ترفضها وهي هدنه في الاصل تملاها
الشقوق
والخروقات المعارضه السوريه فان اكثرها
مصدره قوات الاسد لقد مثل دخول روسيا الى
الصراع في الخريف الفائت دعما قويا لقوات
الاسد ونظامه بعدما اتكا عسكريا على ايران
طيله سنوات وظل يتعثر تقاربت موسكو وطهران
الى حد قيام ما يشبه حلفا غير مفهوم
الهويه بينهما ذلك ربما ما يقود الى ان
تلاقي الاهداف على المدى القصير لا يعني
ذلك بالضروره على المدى البعيد ففي قفز
عالمي اخر فوق الاعتبارات السياسيه
والاخلاقيه لمصالح الشعب السوري وتطلعاته
واماله التي ثار من اجلها يتحدث كبير
العالم الان عن تقسيم واشنطن تلمح اليه
بحديث عن خطباء وروسيا عن فيدراليه تلوح
وتدفع بتعزي يزات عسكريه كبيره الى قاعده
حميميم قلب ظلها العسكري الممتد شرق
المتوسط وعند المصالح تخرج مواقف حاسمه
وربما زاجره فقد سمع الاسد حين قال انه
سيقاتل لاستعاده كل سوريا من دبلوماسي
روسي ما مؤداه ان المهم هو ما سيفعله
الاسد لا ما يقوله هذا ما تشاهده ايران
امامها وهي التي استنفرت معسكرها الى
اقصاه في معركه شدت لاجلها العصبه
السياسيه والدينيه والقومي وكان مشروعها
يتراجع اليوم امام مشروع اكبر بينما تنهمك
هي بدفن شبابها المقتولين في سبيله
والتذكير بذلك في كل
لحظه نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من طهران
الدكتور مصطفى خوش ت ششم استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الامام الصادق من لندن
الكاتب الصحفي السوري بسام جعاره ومن لندن
ايضا الدكتور محمد قواص الكاتب والباحث
السياسي نبدا من طهران والسيد تتشم ما
الذي حصل حتى يقول السيد ولايتي بهذا
الشكل الواضح هذا الرفض للهدنه في
سوريا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وشكرا على
دعوتكم الكريمه الى هذا البرنامج
[موسيقى]
في الواقع للاجابه على هذا
السؤال لابد لنا من ان نراجع وندرس الرؤيا
الايرانيه بصوره اوسع والمتصله باهداف
الولايات المتحده في المنطقه وبشكل خاص في
سوريا وبعد ذلك يمكن ان ننظر في التفاصيل
لكي نفهم جوانب اخرى من ذلك بالنسبه لصوره
العامه الرؤيه الايرانيه فهي على الشكل
التالي تعتبر ايران انه عندما بدا الربيع
العربي بناء على نموذج الثوره الايرانيه
عام 79
فان ترددات هذه الثورات وهذا الربيع
العربي وصلت حتى الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ويمكن ان نرى لا في شرق المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وفيها سكان من الشيعه
ولكن ايضا في الرياض يمكن ان نرى تظاهرات
بالتالي الولايات المتحده
وحلفاؤها وطبعا
الولايات المتحده هي حليف استراتيجي
لمملكه العربيه السعوديه اذا تفاجات بشكل
كبير وحاولت ان توقف مد الربيع العربي
وحاولت كذلك ان تحده عن مساره من خلال
الترويج للتطرف
لدينا اسمحلي سيد ششم يعني مع كامل
الاحترام لما تقوله اذا اذا خذنا في
الربيع العربي وهذا التحليل المستفيض لن
نخرج منه حتى نكون
محددين مختصرين يعني رجاء يعني اسمحلي فقط
بهذه الملاحظه نعود الى الموضوع ما الذي
جعل ولايتي يقول بهذا الوضوح نرفض الهدنه
في
سوريا
نعم هذا هو الاعتقاد السائد في ايران في
اطار هذه الصوره نعتبر ان الولايات
المتحده تحاول القيام بكل شيء لكي
تنسف نظام بشار الاسد العربي بالتالي
ايران تشكك بموقف الولايات المتحده لانه
بغض النظر عن ما تقوم به الولايات المتحده
مع تركيا والمملكه العربيه السعوديه فذلك
في الواقع
بهدف
تعزيز المعارضه والارهاب وذلك لقلب نظام
بشار الاسد في الميدان في شمال سوريا
اليوم وعلى الرغم من ان داعش و جبهه
النصره ليست معنيت بهذه الهدنه هذه الهدنه
تفيد جبهه النصره وداعش هذا ما تقوله
الادله في حلب في شمال حلب على سبيل
المثال في الايام الاربعه الفائته فقد
اكثر من 150 مقاتل اذا هؤلاء الاكراد كذلك
اقتربوا من النظام السوري في الحسك في
الرقه وكذلك في حلب وهم يقولون لقد فقدنا
عددا كبيرا من الناس خلال الايام الاربعه
الفائته لان الروس في الواقع لا يطلعون
بطلعهم الجويه ولا يوفرون الدعم الجوي
وذلك لان هذه الهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار قد
ارسي من جهه
اخرى فان عددا كبيرا من المجموعات
الارهابيه تضرب اليوم الحكومه السوريه في
هذه اللحظه لكن الحكومه السوريه لا ترد
و الروس كانوا قد طلبوا من الحكومه
السوريه عدم القيام بذلك اذا بهذه الطريقه
يمكن للمقاتلين والارهابيين ان يعززوا
صفوفهم بفضل المساعده التي تحصلون عليها
من تركيا تركيا نشرت قوات وبدل ان تساعد
في تعزيز هذه الهدنه فهي في الواقع ادخلت
قوات جديده على الحدود مع سوريا ونشرت
عددا كبيرا كذلك من المدفعيه على طول هذه
الحدود هم يحضرون على ما يبدو بحسب الصور
من السواتل التي نتلقاها يتحضرون لكي
يضربوا الاكراد في ت الابيض ولكن اذا كانت
اسمحلي سييد ششم اذا كانت ايران يشكك في
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده لم تكن
الطرف الوحيد الذي توصل الى هذه الهدنه
هناك الطرف الروسي سيد بسام جعاره الطرف
الروسي شريك للولايات المتحده في هذه
الهدنه ما الذي جعل في النهايه طهران تنظر
الى الهدنه بهذا
الشك المناهض بالكامل
الان رد على ضيفك اليوم قبل ان يتحدث
عندما قال انه يرى في الهدنه بصيص امل
واضح ان هناك حاله تخبط وارتباك وخوف لدى
الجميع بمعنى ايران لها حساباتها بشار له
حساباته واليوم تصريح بشار يتناقض تماما
مع تصريح ولايتي دعني احاول توضيح الصوره
الان الهدنه هي ليست هدنه هي هدنا من طرف
واحد بمعنى ممنوع على الشعب السوري ان يرد
على القصف الجوي الروسي وعلى قيام
المليشيات الطائفيه والحرس الثوري وبشار
الاسد هذا ما ينص عليه القرار لانه يسمح
لبشار ولاير ولروسيا بقصف جميع الارهابيين
اي كل من حمل السلاح ضد بشار الاسد بمعنى
اخر الهدنه هي ليست لصالح الشعب السوري بل
تمكن ال الطرف الاخر من القضاء على ثوره
الشعب السوري بدي اذكر اليوم البوارج
الروسيه اطلقت صواريخ على قريه الزينيه في
في ريف ادلب صواريخ بالستيه والقصر الجوي
الروسي لم يتوقف ابدا وامريكا اعطت روسيا
مهله اشهر قليله للقضاء على الثوره
السوريه ولكن لماذا جاء الموقف الايراني
انا بدي احاول اوضح لك اسبابه الحقيقيه
اولا كان هناك تخوف ايراني واضح من
الطريقه التي تم بها الاعلان على الهدنه
ومن قيام بوتين شخصيا بالاعلان عنها كانت
روسيا كانت ايران تريد ان يستمر قتال كما
جرى في الاشهر الاخيره بمعنى قصف جوي روسي
يحرق الارض وتتقدم القوات الايرانيه على
الارض مع ميليشياتها
الان وصلت تسريبات الى ايران تقول ان
الهدنه ليست مجرد خطوه امنيه او عسكريه بل
هي جزء من تفاهم سياسي ايضا سوف يؤدي
بالمحصب الى رحيل بشار الاسد هنا
استنفرت ايران هي ت تريد الهدنه الان ما
ما دام تسمح لها بالقضاء على المعارضه
ولكنها لا تريدها اذا كانت ستؤدي الى حل
سياسي يفضي برحيل بشار الاسد ايضا ايران
تعرف تماما ان روسيا تتخلى عن حلفائها
تخلت عن القذافي لها موقف اخر من الحوثيين
حلفاء ايران ايضا هناك صراع على الارض
يجري الان بمعنى سباق على الوقت بين ايران
وبين روسيا رو روسيا تحاول شراء ولاء
الضباط والامني على الارض لترسخ وجودها
وتقول روسيا ايضا لحلفائها او للغرب انها
تريد استعاده سوريا من ايران هذا ما يجري
الان وهذا هو سبب غضب ايران نعم ا اذا اذا
الغضب اذا الغضب الايراني هذا سيد بسام
جعاره ارجعته لثلاث نقاط بسرعه حتى نسال
الدكتور محمد قواص تخوف ايراني من الطريقه
التي تم بها الخوف من انه يكون جزء من
تفاهم سياسي يزيح الاسد وهناك خوف من ان
روسيا لم يسبق لها ان كانت وفيه لحلفائها
هل تعتقد سيد محمد قواس ان
هذه ساعود اليك لان لان السيد محمد قواص
لم يتحدث الى حد الان سيد محمد قواص هل
تعتقد بان هذه العوامل كافيه لشرح الموقف
الايراني طبعا واضح جدا ان تصريحات ولايات
التي تستهدف الكلام عن مؤامره امريكيه هي
تصريحات موجهه مباشره الى الحليف بين
مزدوجين الحليف الروسي روسيا هي من تملك
زمام الامور في في سوريا بوتين شخصيا
يعتبر انه هذه الهدنه شبيهه بالصفقه
الكيماويه التي نزعت السلاح الكيماوي من
سوريا سوريا هي روسيا هي التي تقوم
بالاعمال العسكريه التي بامكانها ان تسيطر
على البر والجو والبحر وهي التي بامكانها
ان تقرر مصير الهدنه من عدم مصير الهدنه
واضح جدا ان ان التناقض الروسي الايراني
المؤجل حتى الان بدا شيئا فشيئا يظهر في
ايران اريد ان اذكر بتصريحات صدرت عن احد
كبار موظفي وزاره الخارجيه ال الايرانيه
قبل اشهر عندما قال اتت روسيا لتقطف ما
ضحينا نحن في سوريا وطبعا في هذا المجال
يجب التذكير ان ايران استثمرت الكثير على
مستوى العسكر والمال والايديولوجيا في في
سوريا للبقاء في سوريا كنظام وللبقاء ايضا
كما مر لايران نحو حزب الله في في في
لبنان واضح جدا ان الكلام الجديد عن هدنه
بعد ذلك الكلام عن التقسيم والخطب والكلام
عن الفيدراليه الذي اعلنه نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي يعني ان هناك صفقه بدات
تمر لا سما اذا دققنا اكثر في تصريحات
ولايات الذي يقول ان مصير الاسد يقرره
الشعب السوري لا مؤسسات دوليه او مجلس
الامن بما معنى ان هناك ما ما ما يحضر في
هذا الشان اعتقد ان ايراني يعبر عن قلق
شديد وعن غضب من الحليف الروسي وليس من
الامريكي نذكر بان الاتفاق النووي الشهير
مع ايران هو للانفتاح على الولايات
المتحده الحليف الجديد لايران روسيا تعرف
ان ايران ذاهب في هذا الاتجاه وهي على ال
علم ايضا ان ان مصالحها المشتركه ستختلف
على المدى الطويل وان
كانت حاليا متحالفه على البر مع مع ايران
و وهي تغطيه جوا نعم على كل اذا اذا كانت
ال الصوره بهذا الشكل نريد ان نعرف بعد
الفاصل ما مدى ارتباط هذا الموقف الذي
قدرناه الان بشكل اجمالي على التزام دمشق
ما زلتم معنا في هذه الحلقه التي نتناول
فيها الموقف الايراني من الهدنه في سوريا
وارتباط ذلك بمستوى التزام دمشق بتطبيق
بنودها دكتور تتشم اذا
كانت هناك نوع من الارتباك في الحسابات
لدى اطراف عديده كما تابعنا الان هل
تعتقدون
بان بشار الاسد سيكون اكثر انسجاما مع هذا
الموقف الايراني منه مع الم الامريكي
الروسي في موضوع
الهدنه نعم نعم
طبعا دعوني اشرح واوضح الوقائع في الميدان
يجب ان نتوقع نتحدث عن الوقائع قبل خمسه
اشهر كان بشار الاسد في خطر
لكن بعد هذه الفتره وبفضل المستشارين
الايرانيين وحزب الله والمقاتلين من
العراق
وكذلك الجيش الحر
القوات السوريه
وكذلك الدعم الروسي كان بامكان النظام ان
يطهر مناطق كثيره من حلب الى اللاذقيه
والحسكه وغيرها من هذه المناطق اذا ان
ينظفها من الارهابيين وهم يتقدمون بشكل
سريع لا سما بعد ان تحالف الاكراد مع
الحكومه السوريه وهم في الواقع في موقع
قوه كبيره وما زالوا في هذا الموقع من
القوه بالتالي يطرح السؤال
لماذا نجد ان ايران والحلفاء وبشار الاسد
قبلوا بهذه الهدنه اصلا ذلك بسبب الامور
الانسانيه عندما سلطت وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه على امور بعضها حقيقي وبعضها غير
حقيقي من المعظمي ومن مضايا كثر من الناس
حتى الالاف في كفريا وفي الفوعه وفي ادلب
و
ولكن ولكن سيد ششم يعني حت يعني بعيدا عن
التفاصيل المتعلقه بال بالجانب الميداني
الان عمليا هل ستقبل طهران بان موسكو
وواشنطن هما من اتفق على هذه الصيغه
وسيفرض انها في سوريا سواء اعجب ذلك طهران
ام لم
يعجبها
ان ايران تماما كما روسيا قد قبلت هذه
الهدنه بشار الاسد سوف يحترم هذه الهدنه
لدوافع انسانيه لكن هذا لا يعني ان ايران
لن تدعم بشار الاسد سوف تواصل ايران دعمها
لبشار الاسد فبشار الاسد هو الرئيس الشرعي
لسوريا وايران مقتنع بان مصير سوريا لا
يمكن ان يبت به من خلال النزاعات والحروب
والمعارك او من خلال مجلس الامن التابع
للامم المتحده وقراراته يجب ان يكون ذلك
من خلال الانتخابات وصوت الناس تماما لما
جرى في ايران يوم الجمعه اذا ايران من دون
ادنى الشك سوف تشجع بشار الاسد على ان
يحترم هذه الهدنه تماما كما كانت الحاله
حتى الان ولكن ب ولكن بشار الاسد الان يجد
مجموعه من الحسابات امامه سيد بسام جعاره
ما الذي سيجعله ميالا الى الصيغه
الامريكيه هي الروسيه اكثر من الحليف
الايراني الذي وقف معه منذ البدايات حين
لم تتدخل روسيا او لم يتدخل احد
لنجدته اولا اسمح لي اقول بكل وضوح هذا
الرعب الايراني جاء بعد كلام كيري عن
الخطه باء وبعد ان اوضح قائد قوات التحالف
السابق في حلف النيتو تفاصيل هذه الخطه
التي تقضي باقامه منطقه حظر جوي وتدخل بر
هذا اولا ثانيا تكفل لافروف بارغا ايران
وحزب الله وبشار على القبول بمعنى اخر
بشار لا يستطيع ولا ايران تستطيع ولا احد
يستطيع ان يرفض وعلى الطرف الاخر تكفل
كيري باقناع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وتركيا والمعارضه بقبول الهدنه هذا ما جرى
بكل وضوح ولا احد يستطيع يوم السبت الماضي
اعلن حزب الله رفض الهدنه وتحدث عن تخوفات
كبيره وقال انهم يبيعونها اللي انا بس بدي
يقول كلمه لضيفك لم تاتي روسيا الى سوريا
الا بعد ان هزمت ايران في سوريا بمعنى
ايران هزمت فاضطر الروس الى المجيء ما
الذي يجري الان ما يجري الان هو ان لا احد
يستطيع ان يتصرف بل اكثر من ذلك تلقت
ايران برضا ومع حزب الله القصف الجوي
الاسرائيلي وقالت اسرائيل انها تفاهمت مع
روسيا على قصف كل ما يشكل لها تهديدا
بمعنى القصف الاسرائيلي لقوات حزب الله لم
يتوقف ولن يتوقف ايضا ايران تدرك تماما
انها عميل الان لروسيا وان الحليف هي
اسرائيل هذا ما يجري الان ولا احد يستطيع
الرفض
وا يعني ربما ربما سيد جعاره ربما سيد
جعاره هي غير غير قادره على الرفض لكن هل
هي قادره على الارباك يعني اذا تحركت
القوات الايرانيه او من هم معها بامكانهم
ان ير اي صيغه لوقف اطلاق النار
الان اسمح لي اقول لك بشار الاسد وشبيحته
يفضلون القوات الروسيه مليون مره على
الايرانيين الايرانيون يتحدثون عن جماعه
بشار ك كفار وكان هناك حاله تململ كبرى
وانت رايت والجميع راى كيف تم الترحيب
بالقوات الروسيه ليس فقط لانها قوات غازيه
تنقذ بشار بل ايضا لكي يستريحوا من
ممارسات الايرانيين ولكن الم معادله كانت
بالشكل التالي روسيا لا تستطيع الانتصار
على الارض من الجو وايران لا تستطيع
الانتصار بدون القصف الجوي الروسي بمعنى
كانت هناك معادله ترضي الطرفين ولكن تعرف
ايران تماما ان روسيا تريد استعاده سوريا
منها وبالتالي كل كل ما استثمرته ايران في
سوريا من رجال ومن من اموال تحول الى
مقامره خاسره ادركوا الان انهم سوف يضطرون
او يجبرون على الانسحاب لان لروسيا مصالح
اخرى في العالم ولا بد من التفا الحاله ا
اذا في نعم عفوا يعني اذا في هذه الحاله
مع تشابك هذه الحسابات كلها سيد محمد قواص
ما مسير
الهدنه اعتقد ان الهدنه حتى الان وحتى
اشعار اخر هي في حاله صمود طبعا نسبي هناك
خروقات تسجل يوميا وتنقلها بشكل او باخر
اريد ان اذكر بانه القرار اليوم في سوريا
هو قرار امريكي روسي اساسا روسي يواكبه
الامريكي والاوروبي وكل العالم بما فيها
ايضا قوى اقليميه موجوده اريد ان اذكر بان
جون كيري كان قد اعلن للعالم ان ايران
سحبت قواتها من سوريا ليس بغرض صحفي و
بغرض اعلامي هو امر عمليات امريكي بان على
ايران ان تخرج من سوريا كدوله اذا كان هذا
سيكون مكمل منطقي للاتفاق النووي لا
يستطيع العالم ان يتعامل مع ايران الجديده
لا سما بعد الانتخابات الاخيره لا تستطيع
الشركات الدوليه ان تتعامل مع ايران
الجديده وهي تقوم بهذه الحرب الميليشياوي
في سوريا هناك طبعا شيء واضح ان لا بشار
الاسد ولا الايرانيين باستطاعتهم اليوم ان
يعرقل او يتمردوا على الموقف الامريكي
الروسي اريد ان ايضا ان ان اشدد على ان
روسيا ليست بقرار من فلاديمير بوتين ومن
كرملين في سوريا هناك مواكبه دوليه واضحه
هناك قرار في مجلس الامن واكب الجهد ال ال
الروسي هناك ايضا مواكبه اقليميه اريد ان
اذكر بانه فلاديمير بورتين الرئيس الروسي
قد خبر الملك
السعودي لاقناعه طبعا او لمواكبتها في
موضوع الهدنه بمعنى ان الاقليم يقدم حتى
الان اذا لاحظنا كل الاعتراضات والتحفظات
التركيه لم لم لم تخرج عن الخطوط الحمر
هناك مواكبه لهذا الجهد لا يمكن لا لتركيا
عفوا لا لايران ولا للنظام السوري ان
يعرقل اي حديث عن الهدنه هذا الكلام
الجديد عن اننا نستطيع ان نعرق او نرفض
الهدنه اذا كانوا باستطاعتهم ان يرفضوا
الهدنه فليرفعوه ف فليذهبوا الى الى الى
ضد الى الى ما هو ضد الاراده الدوليه
الامريكيه الروسيه اعتقد انهم اجب من ذلك
اعتقد انهم اعقل من ذلك واعتقد ان ايضا
يجب الاخذ في الاعتبار ان تصريحات ولايات
اتت بعد ساعات من نتائج الانتخابات
الاخيره هي ايضا ممكن اعتبارها الاستهلاك
المحلي الداخلي في ايران شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور محمد قواص الكاتب والباحث السياسي
كنت معنا من لندن شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
لندن بسام الجعاره الكاتب الصحفي السوري
ومن طهران شكرا ايضا للدكتور مصطفى خوش
تشم استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جماعه
الامام
الصادق في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
م